my name is ly
Nelson my name is
lesli deep breath my name is Liam n and
I
feel like I want to
sing I feel a bit nervous about sitting
here with my old palone on a brand you
should be nervous very excited you
should be nervous Liam cuz you know me
I've got a temper yes and I know how to
use these mths you know so if you get
out of L
it's going to get rough for you you know
that don't you you'll come for me you'll
find me
I I have certain skills what skills do
you have in real life by the way you
always you've one of the most famous
lines in action movies I've got a
particular set of SK skills what do you
what skills do you have in real life
what can you
do um I would love to be able to say I
have a skill at fly fishing mhm I've
been flying fish
for 23 24 years
yeah and I'm competent right don't you
that's not as threatening to say to a
kidnapper over the phone now listen to
me now listen to me I don't have any
money if that's what you're after but I
am a competent fly Fisher fly fisherman
Catch and
Release but you I will not
release
come on remake it that way I promise you
people are going to absolutely love it
you know it is great to see you we we uh
We've run into each other a couple of
times over the years we've talked and uh
we always have this crazy Bond I don't
know if it's a genetic thing
because I don't know I I found out since
I met you that I'm 100% Irish after my
people have been in this country since
1875 still genetically we just married
each other and had more kids and uh 1870
you know I'm sorry the history of the
plummet yeah 1875 was a nanc ago just
just happened yeah yeah so I do think I
don't know what it is but I know first
time I met you you may not remember this
I've only been to one prize fight in my
life one boxing match and you I I
someone took me I'd never been to one
before and I stood up and you came over
and said oh hello Conan let's go get a
pint because it was in between bouts and
I thought oh this is fantastic Liam niss
is inviting me for a pint and uh so what
was the main event I don't I mean this
is how bad I am I don't remember I
remember people were hitting each other
that's how I'm not I'm not I don't
follow the sport someone invited me
right and I thought these guys seem
angry people no no they're supposed to
be doing this we're supposed to be
hitting each other I don't don't
remember what it was but we went and we
got a we got a pint together and I
thought this is living having a pint
with Liam niss this is about as cool as
it gets and I it was a great time you
were very nice to me and then we've uh
We've run into each other every now and
then I know my people are all from the
south yes by the coast and I know that
you're a you're a northern fella I uh
Northern Ireland little time called
balina yeah 30 Mi Northwest of Belfast
but my mother is uh born a boy was born
in Brad Waterford in the Irish Republic
where Waterford by the Sea yes that's
where my people are from get away yeah
seriously I will not get away I am here
to stay um I we are from uh Waterford
and uh on my father's side yes so you
and I are related we know that they have
to be yeah and uh I remembered I went
first time I went back to Ireland I sto
somewhere that I was told was Waterford
and I get out of the car and you know
you're supposed they say You're supposed
to kiss kiss the ground so I thought
okay I'll kiss the ground and as I'm
kissing the ground someone went by and
said what are you doing and I said well
from Waterford they went this isn't
Waterford spitting it out spitting out
soil they said it's you know 30 mil that
way you ass so uh yeah but uh but it's
it's funny because there is something I
don't know what it is um when it's in
there's something in the blood where
when I meet other people who are Irish
even though I've not grown up in that
country and you could say I'm not really
Irish because I you know third
generation or fourth generation in this
country uh I do right away like every
cell in my body says this is the air I'm
supposed to be breathing sure um I like
that it's raining out
yes rain yes everyone's depressed
yesh people aren't taking care of
themselves this is the way I'm meant to
live not in Southern California which is
a terrible terrible Mist yeah but I I I
I find g I'm born and Brad
palamina uh Catholic ah boy because
everybody always asks yeah um but when I
came out to the
states uh 0 1988 I'm an American citizen
very PR on to and Irish citizen but
everybody I'd meet wanted to tell me
they had a connection with either
Ireland or Scotland yeah I was for
somebody to say I'm an American yeah do
you know what I mean yeah they always
wanted to make a connection it made me
think yeah okay there was a million and
a half during the Potato Famine in
Ireland 1845
1852 came out here right in coffin boats
they were on coffin ships you know and I
was like oh I of course 1845 that was
that was a nanc ago you know two seconds
ago but it's also I mean uh I I I've
always got embarrassed on St Patrick's
Day here in the States because people
that were 11 18th Irish paint the Irish
flag on their face get shitfaced throw
up on Fifth Avenue um and kiss everyone
they see after throwing
up IR what when did you how Irish are
you my father's uncles brothers sisters
mothers cuz your last name's Armenian ah
you I'm Irish and I think well you
just wanted to get drunk and then I find
out that in Ireland on St Patrick's Day
they they people go to mass they go to
mass yeah no one's painting their face I
know no one's celebrating this
Insanity uh so you're raised Catholic so
we both had that because I was raised
very Catholic and did you do uh you an
alter boy I was not an alter boy they
found out early on this kid can read and
he's good at speaking so we'll make him
a Lecter which means I'll read the
passages when they need someone to read
a passage so I got a speaking part which
was kind of nice I I looked at the alter
boys and I thought I like that
outfit and I want that Smoky thing I
want to I want to toss that Smoky thing
around that that's terrible
Conor I'm sorry we I'm sorry here in
America Next older boy in here in
America we call it the Smoky thing and
if you're going to be a citizen of this
country you need to learn
that uh so um commun the whole thing I
found communion Terri I mean not
communion uh confession I found
confession terrifying I would always
freeze up when I would go into the
confessional because I wouldn't know I
just I didn't want to admit to anything
real and I would freeze up so I'd make
things up that no kid would do I I am I
embezzled check you embezzled from a I
store put funds in an offshore account
and didn't declare it how old are you
I'm seven
I coveted my neighbor's wife what did
you not really I just would freeze up
did you did you get did you find that
frightening I I did especially the last
confession I ever went to officially
confessional and I think it was I wasn't
16 I was 15 I know I was still boxing
and uh it was a great event when you had
a missionary visiting from Africa or
something like that yeah yeah and it
there for a week and you'd go to mass
every night and as an older boy I'd be
serving
Mass uh but to hear for the to hear your
confession from him it was like a big
deal so I remember going 15 years of age
and it was before mass and there were
lots of old women just outside the
confessional kneeling down and sing
their prayers and I went into this guy
and he's used to be in in Africa Congo
whatever Shing his lungs
I
so we started and I
had um I had learned how to pleasure
myself at home onto the sheets right
yeah sure and I looked up the
appropriate word I remember this about
masturbate masturbation okay that seems
harmless enough I'd say that me Father
argued with my mom yeah my sister and I
fight and
uh I masturbated you
what this guy literally oh my God I mean
he he almost said things like the grass
will grow out of the palm of your hand
before you're
21 stop that evil practice he's shouting
this and I'm immediately thinking I have
to leave this and there's all these old
women praying outside who can hear
everything you can hear everything
especially
him and I laughed and my dick my dick
was that size it just shrinks up inside
you yeah that was the last time I ever
want to I think that'll do it yeah I
think that'll do it that's my
God it wasn't Happ and I'm all pride of
myself I haven't learned this word you
know well I'm glad I never masturbated
that's all I'll
say